はいこんにちははじめシャツをねー夏といえばもうあれですよ
海でで海グレストーン弓なんですけど
浮き輪とかいろいろあるじゃないですか浮き輪ボート
浮き輪ボート仏器は頭としかないは僕は今回ですね
もうとんでもない愛でも仕入れました
卵いていきましょう
ええええええ
[音楽]
じゃあこれねお届けないっちゃうでしょなにこれ
いや何か白いんとやばいねーかこれ
これだけ見たちょっと何か分からないんですけどいわゆる水上歩行ができるんですけど
ビズの上を are you doing
ベッカーこんなんではなくての考えていた方がいえなかである家なぁ広げちゃダメだな
自社にも外でね夏を楽しんでねあの安倍首相方向で今日はネタのショーと思いますし
じゃあ外に入ってくる
おはようございます
ゾンビ de サッカーボールを外に持ってきて膨らましてね
膵臓保護しようとますめんどくせー
ねぇねぇねっ
フェリーなぜぶりのん naoki さんでもめっちゃ
ますのでどうぞ
う指でナースとだねっ
できましたん
ん
結構配ったり来なかったんですよ
ねこれいいのかなほんと合計が入んなきゃいけないんですねサックを開けて僕が入ら
なきゃいけない
もう今から空けてずっとことがことがに入ります
さあ
ああああああ
バーンリー戦を大事にしていたママスーツ
1ん
坊
up a 者のんだか
ren
91年間ん
居住 h 2
世界観だよ
voodoo
dearheart
[音楽]
maroo
あああーーでーえぬあああーーーーああ